name is Roger Hannah my PhD concerned
the polarization of annihilation at
radiation this was in the late 1940s the
point was the two gamma rays traveling
in opposite directions which resulted
are polarized at right angles now say
the first electron the first gamma-ray
sorry is goes to an analyzer the guard
that gets through or it doesn't and
depending what has happened to it it
mysteriously communicates with the other
gamma-ray mister what will happen to it
when it goes through the it's an
analyzer and this has always been a
total mystery to me and various
explanations but none of them really add
up and I gather the subject is still
alive it's the subject of entanglement
which I would like to have disentangle I
Roger so you're asking me to disentangle
or or try to explain to you the
phenomena the quantum mechanics of
entanglement which is a very subtle and
difficult concept since quantum
mechanics is so unusual strange from the
point of view of our everyday classical
experience in quantum mechanics you can
indeed prepare a system of two photons
with opposite polarizations easily as
you did and separate those two photons
by large distances perform an experiment
on one photon determining its
polarization at which point you
immediately know the polarization of the
other photon must be reverse and that
other photon might be very far away from
you and expect you know what the result
of an experiment on the other side of
the galaxy would be even though you
could not by any means we know community
that result to that experimenter some
people find this very strange indeed
Einstein who raised this concept as one
of his objections to the two quantum
mechanics felt that it was an indication
that quantum mechanics had to fail
someplace because it suggested as you
remark yourself that there was some
communication between these two photons
on opposite sides of the galaxy and yet
we believe that information can't be
communicated faster than the speed of
light later in the 60s john bell a
scottish theoretical physicist made this
much sharper by proposing certain tests
of exactly such a hypothetical
experiments which could distinguish
between a quantum mechanical description
which simply says yes there is a
correlation between these photons no
matter how far apart they are and that
is not explained by any kind of hidden
variable theory and things communicating
with each other to establish the
correlation it's just the way we
describe nature that's quantum mechanics
and a potential theory that Einstein
would have been satisfied with of hidden
variables but one in which you cannot
have signals traveling faster than the
speed of light these the the ability to
distinguish between those then became in
experimental questions and in
fascinating experiments over the last 20
years
experimenters have verified with
increasing precision
careful measurement that quantum
mechanics works and the hidden variable
deterministic theories that Einstein was
proposing simply are inconsistent with
experiment that doesn't that resolves
the issue of the validity of quantum
mechanics at least with respect to this
question but it doesn't satisfy many
people who are still we still have the
desire as Einstein did to construct a
classical description of reality that
somehow is behind of the quantum of the
quantum mechanical description of
reality which we use to correctly
describe these kinds of phenomena I
don't know how to tell you more I think
you will have to simply get used to it
the world is quantum mechanical and it
is perfectly consistent which is that is
the framework we use to describe nature
now to have a description in which
objects that are far apart and do not
communicate with one another are still
correlated there's nothing inconsistent
about that which is why it works so well
it's just hard to get used to